foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday October 19th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
social media is often talked about in
terms of the negative effects it can
have on young users but it's a growing
number of more positive and authentic
apps that are catching on with teens one
in particular gas is leaning into that
positivity
gas asks teens multiple choice questions
about people in their school and lets
them vote on say the most beautiful
person they've ever met or the classmate
who is never afraid to get in trouble
the approach seems to be catching on
as of last Friday it was the most
popular free iPhone app according to
data AI it's been downloaded more than
500 000 times since late August and it's
not even available in all 50 states yet
that's great news for the app's Founders
who previously built a similar app and
sold it to Facebook before it became
meta so what lessons can gas learn from
that experience and what might it teach
other social media platforms about
attracting teens joining us to discuss
this is our personal Tech reporter
Anne-Marie Alcantara hi Anne-Marie
thanks for joining us Hey Zoe thanks for
having me
so what is it about this app that makes
it so popular with young people I think
people like it because it's sort of
positive you can't create the questions
and polls so you can't say like who has
the worst smile or who do I hate sitting
next to in lab it's very geared towards
making sure people don't feel bad when
they log on and vote on on these polls
so you're voting in these polls that
tend to be positive but are there
downsides or drawbacks to the app itself
there always are to like any social
media app you know as you can imagine
people might feel left out people might
think they're not being voted on or you
know why didn't they get voted on for
having the best smile or whatever the
category might be but one of the
co-founders to tell me that you know
they created this algorithm that if
you're not being voted on them in polls
you know they're going to start
surfacing your name more so you don't
feel left out what about other downsides
that we've seen from other apps like
data collection or the use of your
information yeah so this app based on
what one of the co-founders told me
they've made it very clear that privacy
is naturally one of their top concerns
and so even in the sign up process you
know you're prompted to like show your
contacts or your location so that you
can start pre-populating polls or get
matched to your high school faster but
you don't have to do that you can choose
not to do those things and then find
these things on your own and they've
also said if you do share your location
it's not associated with your account or
store word on their servers and another
feature that they've also implemented is
not allowing direct messages on the app
so if someone did try to bully you or
say you don't deserve to win best smile
or or whatever the poll was no one can
do that at least on the app the founders
of gas also had another app TBH can you
tell us a bit about that app and how
it's different from gas yes so five
years ago TBH was around similar concept
and climbed the App Store charts really
really quickly as well there were a few
different features like you could direct
message someone and so now one of the
co-founders of that app created gas and
he's done things in this app such as
creating that algorithm that surfaces
your name if you haven't been voted on
in polls and it has this in-app currency
that rewards you if you are voting for
people more so what happened with TBH
then why did they switch to gas
so TBH because of its popularity was
acquired by at the time the company we
know now is meta Facebook Inc and it was
alive and around for probably almost a
year after the acquisition and then in a
blog post Facebook said there was load
usage so they shut down the app
let's talk a little bit about
competition that they have because
there's been this boom of authentic or I
guess kind of more positive social media
apps being really popular with teens you
know be real is one locket is another so
can you give us a sense of what the
competition is going to be like for gas
and how sustainable its growth might be
given that I mean the competition really
depends on teens and what they're
looking for maybe they'll get sick and
tired of being
positive and too authentic and want to
you know move to another app where they
can be a little more real and share
their thoughts even if it's maybe a
little mean I think we are seeing the
shift though towards people moving
to these apps that are not curated that
they don't have any filters that it's
just kind of a nice little safe space
and you know it's a select group of
friends as well it's not everyone you
might know in school or in your life
what about in terms of business growth
for these apps I mean how are they going
to make money in the long term
that's the million dollar maybe billion
dollar question
but I think with many of these apps you
see them looking to introduce ads
um in the case of gas they do have
multiple features you can pay for and
you know that's some incremental revenue
and yeah that's the question do you
introduce ads and sort of add friction
to the experience or do you introduce
currency and subscriptions and then make
people pay for the service that was once
free and fun I wonder given the growth
that you're talking about in terms of
the social media market now the
experience that the gas Founders had
with their previous app TBH shutting
down after you know maybe becoming less
popular if we're going to see that kind
of ShakeOut happening in this social
media space soon are we going to see
that maybe some of these apps can't
survive or don't have the same following
or is there enough room for all of them
you know we've seen in this happen in
the past few years as well you know I'm
maybe dating myself a bit but I was
around during the days of Yik Yak and yo
and all these other apps that had
similar premises you know of sort of
connecting with your friends in a
one-off sort of
Anonymous type way and many of those
apps are now gone because you know to
your other question they couldn't
sustain a great business model so
unclear what will happen the market is
totally crazy and there's definitely
room for opportunity as we've seen of
tick tock and be real for apps to really
go viral but yeah the next question is
absolutely what will they do to maintain
that growth and of course pay themselves
make sure that they can sustain the
server capacity all these questions all
right we guess we'll just all have to
wait and see that's our personal Tech
reporter and Marielle quintera thanks
for joining us thank you
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]